chemokines are small chemo attractant
agents that induce cell movement to a
higher concentration here are some cells
like neutrophils and macrophages which
has encountered a pathogen they would
immediately secrete chemokines to
attract more of their friends like Morse
neutrophils and more macrophages
so by sensing the concentration gradient
a neutrophil or any cell can reach the
site of infection that is why chemokine
gradients matter
hemokines can lead to several cellular
changes via chemical in signaling
chemokine receptors are G protein
coupled receptor so they would activate
gpcr signaling which in a downstream
manner would activate cell movement cell
survival or via rasmap kinase signaling
they can help in cell growth
proliferation and cell survival
besides that chemokine has profound role
in inflammation and in cancer
progression